CPAC now we're gonna really change
topics here because CPAC the
conservative political action committee
also known as the cantina scene from
Star Wars the circus of odd characters
that they bring out there they were
going on it's going on for a couple days
at the gaylord hotel which really you
can't make this stuff up and instead of
bringing guys like Chris Christie
moderates in the party they doubled down
on clowns like Donald Trump and Ann
Coulter let's listen to a little of
sweet and musings thank you as some of
you know due to the turmoil in North
Korea our regularly scheduled speaker
ambassador dennis rodman will not be
here so i'm i'm filling in I'm Ann
Coulter the author of nine mess of New
York Times bestsellers boy the sequester
is really ruined everything hasn't it
they're little kids can't go on White
House tours Muslim Brotherhood has been
deprived of 250 million oh no that's
safe sorry that's fine even CPAC had to
cut back on his speakers this year by
about 300 pounds
ha Ann Coulter should teach stand-up
comedy is not she wickedly brilliant
lordy Lordy um ok so to start here why
is it that the Republicans pundits are
actually more ridiculous than their
candidates who often are quite
ridiculous Brian I posed that to you to
start you know I think the way I look at
ann coulter cuz it's like I think she's
kind of like that racist relative
everybody has it always makes racist and
offensive comments better as I go hahaha
my uncle so-and-so you know and I think
she kind of represents that for that
party like oh she can see those crazy
things and will laugh and it's okay cuz
she's hurt yeah you know that and I
think it's why it appeals so it gives
them a little familiarity to graduate
with right yeah and everything is if it
would be one thing if she was very Pro
certain things but I think she says her
are so mean I mean like you have to have
a sense of humor about yourself and I
think we all need to lighten up in many
contexts but she's not she's saying
offensive things about people who she is
adamantly against and that's the problem
we need to get big and coulter i mean
you know what the funny thing is like
now you look at CPAC and you know they
have metallica as enter entering songs
they have hype men essentially i feel
like CPAC has become like the WWE of
like political around like it's really
ridiculous I mean Ann Coulter no she's
like this praying mantis of a politician
or in the political world you know I
just she's like beautiful and sexy and
like a kind of like you want to hit her
kind of way and like I just picture her
ripping the heads off of men that she
sleeps with after well she does look
like the alien from Independence Day
doesn't she very long and like she's
gonna read your mind and then crush you
yeah David what does this say about the
state of the party that they're pundits
are more over the top you know they
bring it in Trump and yet chris Christie
doesn't get invited what does that say
look here's the thing i think i mean the
round of applause that she got in front
of the conservatives was kind of wimpy
and weak i I think if you're a Democrat
you want Ann Coulter exactly where she
is because Ann Coulter talks to a base
but it
not a very big base and so I think you
know as much as she offend you know I
met her at church one time in west
hollywood where the gays hang out why
are they get our side by why do the gays
why the gay obsession as you said
there's something slightly sexy and
sultry and kind of like I'd be down to
have a beer with you or a cocktail about
Ann Coulter regardless of the hate she
may spew there's something laughable
about her this is very bizarre ya know
but at the end the day though like I
could never like been in a day she's
against Who I am as a person yeah screw
you like I have like nothing to do that
I don't understand it I know there is a
lot of gay men are like oh my god she's
fabulous in it up [ __ ] you like
seriously sorry I mean no you might say
that I think it's so stupid I think how
could you be friends would be someone
who's so who makes fun of you and says
really offensive things about you all
the times you know anti-woman anti-gay
right anti really everything that
matters of my life yeah I mean no I but
you're saying you understand it at some
level don't be gay there's a lot of
reason a rational you can't sit down
with her and have an emotional
discussion right she'll rip you to
shreds with you know insults and all
that so when you take her for what she
is and when you realize she is part of
an extreme fringe that each year seems
to be kind of squeezed more and more I
mean every time I turn around its like
her and sean hannity yelling in some
corners but people are listening and you
know as a new poll comes out on more
American supporting gay marriage and as
Democrats continue to win elections it
will change its eventual but in the
meantime I kind of like her she makes me
laugh and then he's so ridiculous you're
sorry it kind of makes me laugh and it's
fun to watch well ironically she may be
the best comedian that Republic which is
really she should be your idol she
should be my sidekick I think it was
money you can have her here next week
Colter and have I did you have a go to
church in West Hollywood that is all you
gotta do st. Victor's Church in West
Hollywood she sits in the second to last
pew on the back of the church and
Coulter if you find a funny jus hunting
you down at church that will be me and
I'd love to have you on the show don't
forget the official outfitter of the
Ruben report is bonobos calm enter code
TR are 20 for twenty percent off your
next shirt